Це загальноосвітня школа з польською мовою навчання на Львівщині
У прикордонному місті Мостиська
велика польська громада, багато і змішаних українсько-польських родин
Вдома тут часто говорять польською,
але в місті панує українська
Батьки прагнуть, аби їхні діти знали обидві мови
Діти народилися в Україні,
і українську вони повинні знати
Саме перше. А потім вже не буде перешкоди
щоб вони знали польську, англійську
Відповідно до чинних законів
нині в цій школі 40 відсотків предметів викладаютьукраїнською мовою
60 відсотків - польською
Те, як ми тут прикордонне містечко, в нас немає такої
чисто польської розмовної мови
Правда. Я їм не можу цього передати
В мене все є змішане
А тут я знаю, що їх цього навчать
Утім, з 1 вересня школи національних меншин
очікують кардинальні зміни
Згідно з новим законом "Про освіту"
у початковій школі діти можуть
навчатися рідною мовою
а от з 5-го класу більшість предметів
мають викладатися державною
Цей закон спрямований на покращення володіння державною мовою національними меншинами
особливо у Західній Україні, де у багатьох селищах
мешкають переважно поляки, угорці чи румуни
От тільки у Мостиській школі вважають
що їм не потрібне збільшення кількості
предметів українською мовою
Мовляв, випускники і так демонструють
добрі результати ЗНО
По суті, ми не знаємо
як ми далі будемо існувати, що буде
У нас проблем нема
Українська мова читається на високому рівні
польська на високому
Я би не сказала, щонам
потрібні в нашій школі якісь зміни
Новий закон України про освіту викликав чимало критики
у Польщі, Угорщині та Румунії
які вимагають забезпечити право національних меншин
на навчання рідною мовою
У Мостиській школі сподіваються
що законодавство буде дещо змінене
і скорочення кількості предметів польською мовою вдасться уникнути
Вчителі розраховують на європейський підхід
Польське законодавство передбачає три варіанти
вирішення "мовного питання"
у навчальному процесі
Перший - це школи для національних меншин
де усі предмети вивчають рідною мовою,
окрім польської мови, географії та історії Польщі
Другий варіант - двомовна школа
де щонайменше 4 предмети на вибір школи
викладають мовою нацменшини
Третій варіант – коли усе викладають польською
і пропонують факультатив рідної мови
найближчий до українського сценарію
Знати державну мову в Польщі -
обов’язок кожного громадянина
каже директор цієї двомовної
української школи в Перемишлі
Це взагалі не обговорюється
Водночас він не відчуває і жодної дискримінації щодо права навчання рідною мовою
В нашій школі кількість уроків української мови
є така сама, як кількість годин польської мови
Так що, оскільки, наприклад, один клас
в тиждень має 5 годин польської мови
стільки саме також 5 годин
учні мають української мови
Українською мовою учні також вивчають
географію і історію України,
а ще -  українські традиції
Наталя навчається грати на бандурі
ще з першого класу
Відчуваєш ніби якусь таку
єдність з Україною
Учні польської школи в українському місті Мостиська
теж мають можливість не втрачати
єдності зі своїм корінням
Діти знають і польські пісні, і танці
А їхні батьки шанують польські релігійні традиції
Та які б зміни в законодавстві не відбувалися
самі діти по обидва боки кордону розуміють
що їм треба знати і українську, і польську
А краще - ще кілька мов
щоб бути конкурентоспроможними
на великому ринку освіти та праці Євросоюзу